but yeah Harry and Megan out of Frogmore
back to Montecito dropped by Spotify
about to be dropped by Netflix no bugger
wants to invite them anywhere and we all
hate them just a joke don't if you're
dead don't be offended it's just a joke
thank you for wearing blacks very
miserable day Kenzie Schofield we love
you we're not going to finish with the
dance song we're just gonna say we hope
she gets better reputational management
good God that's all I have time for
tonight I'm going off to meet a
reputational management PR but you're
not going anywhere because the main man
of this network is up next ladies and
gentlemen standby Piers Morgan
uncensored next on talk
tonight Manchester City just made Global
Headlines by winning three of the
biggest trophies in football but was it
won fairly the club faces more than 100
charges of financial rule breaking
tonight we'll add bombshell bombshell
New Revelations about those charges and
we'll debate the Middle East takeover of
sport
also tonight the cost of living like a
king you figure showed World spending as
rocketive I think they're worth every
penny but I'll debate with two Royal
naysayers who don't think they're worth
anything
possibility sets John Mountain
sensationally bans vegans from his
restaurant to protect he says his mental
health is this the way to deal with the
vegan fund police he joins me live
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored good
evening from London welcome to
Pittsburgh whether you like it or not
many don't many do the Middle East is
hitting World sport like a ballistic
missile oil Rich states with Bottomless
Pits of cash are spending Untold wods of
their desert dollars on buying up the
games that we love a competing furiously
with each other they're transforming
Sport and they're just getting started
Qatar plowed 220 billion dollars into
the World Cup formula one is in Saudi
Arabia Bahrain Qatar Abu Dhabi Dubai
boast major boxing ballots that would
have once been a shoeing for Vegas or
New York the saudi-backed live golf has
just turned that sport upside down now
it's sensationally merging with the PGA
Tour and next societies are planning a
massive swing into professional tennis
and of course they want the biggest
sport of all football the beautiful game
well they're in the Premier League as
owners of Newcastle United and barely a
day seems to pass without another major
star following Cristiano Ronaldo to the
desert Kingdom for eye-watering Suns but
this Sporting Arms Race All Began
arguably with the UAE the emirati's
bought Manchester City back in 2008 it's
now become the jewel in the Middle East
sporting Crown City were a middling Club
The Ugly Duckling of Manchester forever
in the shadows of Manchester United but
not anymore it's United in the shadows
of city city have spent billions turning
City into the champions of Europe they
just beat my beloved Arsenal to the
Premier League title their seventh of
the shake mansor it's a sole subject for
us gooners of course so you might think
perhaps like I do that there's something
wrong with it and maybe there is we'll
debate that later tonight but the key
question we're asking first is is it
fair was it a Level Playing Field did
Manchester City actually play by the
rules that have been laid down they've
now been charged with more than 100
breaches of Premier League Financial
regulations and tonight we're going to
reveal New Revelations which will
uncover a little bit more about those
charges well joining me now is the times
Chief Sports correspondent Matt Lawton
to talk us through it plus talk to you
the international editor Isabella shot
and the former Vice chairman of Arsenal
David Dean and remotely by the
conservative MP and former chair of the
commons culture media and Sport
committee Damien Collins well thank you
all for joining me okay Matt tonight the
times is breaking a story which reveals
some detail of these charges against
Manchester City what is it and how
significant is it it's a specific detail
which is supported by documents it's
supported by the fact that there is a
new film that is obtained a UEFA report
that was into City these allegations of
financial doping if you like at
Manchester City
and specifically what you've got what
you've got to do if you roll back in
time
City awry these guys arrive and they
they own City
and they want they've got so much money
but there are rules that limit how much
they can spend it so the allegations
really are around the fact that whether
they were using slightly underhand ways
to spend the money faster to to close
the gap on on the arsenals and the
Manchester United's quicker in this
specific case what we have are are two
payments of 15 million pounds in 2012
and 2013 so 30 million in total by a
mystery figure now UEFA looked at this
person uh Yaba Muhammad and they
couldn't actually identify who he was
but what's what's important about this
story is the fact that actually when it
came to it a lot of what UEFA looked at
when they investigated Manchester city
was time barred and they had a five-year
limit that's not the case with the
Premier League and we're pretty certain
that of the 115 charges that sit that
City are facing from the Premier League
and that's the thing when we talk about
City winning the winning the treble two
and a half weeks ago it's hard you have
to still look at it within the context
of these charges that are hanging over
them we're pretty confident this will be
one of the charges and this is the kind
of thing just just this random simple
Layman's language just shoving money
there's 30 million pounds have come in
from this mystery donor who's not an
official sponsor no he's and who do we
think he is who do we think he
represents well we think he's not far
removed from the you know from the
people that run the countries and if
that is the case is that a clear breach
of premier league rules yes because it
because it's not a sponsorship deal it's
not legitimate ship deal the point is
when you are City in 2012 2013 you you
know in 2023 they are now the richest
club in the world the most successful
they attract all the sponsorship they
attract all the money because they're
winning everything so everyone wants to
sponsor them but back then even though
they were going to win the title
um you know they're winning their first
title back then they're not commanding
the sums they need to spend far yeah
that Squad that Pep Guardiola has just
won the trouble with Costa the best part
of a billion pounds to assemble so
you've got to spend that money and they
had to spend money fast to get into a
position where they could really what
are the repercussions if they're found
guilty of a number of these charges like
the one that the times is reporting
tonight if they're found guilty what
happens well the the the options open to
the Premier League are pretty extensive
including relegating them from the
Premier League would they remove this
recently won premier league title and
would that automatically go to the club
that came second well unfortunately for
Arsenal the the the the the the the the
span of the time span of the charges is
2009 to to to 2018. but you could argue
the whole edifice has been built on what
they did in those first few years
absolutely if that was all done
illegally breaking the rules of the
Premier League it's pretty serious I
mean David look you've been at the
Forefront of all this one of the Premier
League's great you know creators what do
you make of this I'm not sure how much
of a Smoking Gun this really is in the
scheme of things and whatever you say
Manchester City and I'm not here to
defend Mountain City they've done a
sensational job not just for themselves
but for the Premier League 115 charges I
understand that then they're still going
to be proven yet but only one of them
here out of 113 million oh no they're
innocent until proven guilty sure
there's a lot of long way to go yet
they'll probably travel along for the
next couple of years in any case I
cannot see them having any titles taken
away from them I think that would be
wrong in the scheme of things but let's
see uh what the argument is we're going
to come back to the I want to come back
to the wider debate about this Sports
washing concept but let me bring in a
Damian Collins so Damien what do you
make of this this whole situation around
city and the sort of central charge I
guess that these 115 charges which
they're facing relating to the first few
years that they were involved with this
big takeover by shaped manso if it turns
out that they really were
masking and concealing vast sums of
money which has then led to them
becoming the biggest club in the world
what should be done about this
well there should be some sanction
against them and I think that can't just
be a fine which will be irrelevant to
Manchester city has to be some sort of
in-game sanction and I think these 115
charges aren't a trivial matter
sometimes when you hear people talking
about this it makes it sound like this
is these are details for lawyers this is
about the Integrity of the competition
if clubs are willingly breaking the
rules for their own advantage to give
them a competitive Advantage within
those sporting competitions they have to
be robust sporting sanctions I think it
also shows there has to be proper robust
independent Financial oversight of
football clubs as well I think too much
of this takes place within the sport and
also it's too easy for very wealthy
clubs to use lawyers to frustrate
investigations for years it needs to be
much more transparent than it's been so
far I mean the bottom line is that
that should be state-owned right but a
lot of clubs are already it looks to me
circumnavigating that they're sort of
setting up entities which are clearly
linked to States and they're getting
around it that way should we be
tightening the loopholes on this
yeah I think that's that's why we need
to have this much discussed football
regulator in the UK where there's proper
transparency of financial records this
isn't just done within the sporting
competitions themselves but actually
there's an external body that's got the
right to know who's who are the ultimate
owners of the club where are the funds
coming from are they trading within the
financial Fair player rules because what
a lot of fans will feel is a club is
bought effectively by Sovereign wealth
fund we're a very rich entity billions
of pounds are pumped in now where's that
money going for how's it being spent
because it distorts the competition for
everyone else if clubs are breaking the
financial rules and what we've got to
avoid I think is football being owned by
a very small number of people who are
the only people who've got the resources
to buy some of these clubs and operate
them and the way they're being run now
right Isabel let's look at this in a
bigger picture of sports washing this
new phrase I'm kind of torn on it
because I think there's obviously a
degree of sports washing obviously a lot
of these Middle Eastern countries would
like to improve their images
particularly the ones like Saudis have
got you know poor human rights records
and so on and it's right they should be
held accountable for the human rights
abuses and so on but it's also true I've
seen it with my friend Cristiano Ronaldo
over in Saudi the amazing impact he's
been having on football there but also
the reaction of the young Saudi football
fans they're football nuts over there
and we saw the Qatar World Cup teams
like Morocco and others huge oh who
huge rest in the region uh why should
they not be able to go around the world
investing in sport that their own people
absolutely love what is intrinsically
wrong with that even if along the way
there is clearly an element of sports
watching well as Damien Collins was
saying there it's about transparency
isn't it and I think you make a very
fair point here about the actual impact
that it's having back in those countries
and I think to me what this shows is the
astonishing level
is in the Middle East at the moment I
mean several countries that are plowing
huge sums of money into getting involved
in sport as part of a kind of whole
overhaul of their International image
for geopolitical reasons and the
government here has I think rightly
taken a very pragmatic view of that you
know taking Saudi Arabia as an example
we basically need them you know we must
we still we still have arms deals with
Saudi Arabia 40 we still buy 40 percent
of our oil from Saudi Arabia the qataris
own half of London I mean there's a lot
of hypocrisy I found around the Qatar
World Cup I mean Matt if you come to the
way that journalists in this country
have covered all this it's a lot of like
a sort of angry reaction from British
journalists about sports watching and
how wrong it all is but ultimately if
you are City fans you ask Newcastle fans
you ask golf fans we're not going to see
their biggest Styles in the world come
together for some collective competition
whatever it may be if you ask most
sports fans
about the huge injections of cash I
don't think there is morally problematic
about it as perhaps journalists here are
I think we were right just as you've
done it just now I think we were right
to to question some of the human rights
issues going into Qatar and even before
the football started
um particularly when they're
confiscating rainbow hats off people and
stuff like that the sort of PR own goals
that were happening but if that's their
culture you know you can't expect to go
into another country and they have they
are concerned well England won the World
Cup in 1966 it was actually illegal to
be gay in this country well you know
people how would we have felt if people
to come along with rainbow Flags then
they'd have been taken down they'd have
been arrested I do think you have plenty
evolves yeah but I do think the idea
that England in particular it takes
more High Ground we invaded Iraq
illegally in my opinion it's just my
opinion invaded Iraq illegally uh calls
Mayhem in the Middle East and yet
somehow we think we are morally pure
enough to lecture the Middle East about
how they should conduct I'm not
I think the reporting was balanced
because the messaging before the World
Cup was that everyone was welcome and
then people were made to feel they
weren't welcome and you know we
interviewed gay football fans out there
who didn't feel welcome anyway but but
wasn't that because you lot told them
they were well because what I found on
the streets of Qatar I was having a
great time it was you going up to gay
people saying do you feel welcome wasn't
it
you know I would read some of the stuff
but anyway
um look it's on sportswashing generally
yeah is there a line between genuine
Sports watching which I'm sure they're
all trying to do wash their human rights
records improve their image but also
genuine recognition that they really do
want to get involved in sport and
actually if the sport benefits like golf
tremendously from Grassroots up from
vast injections of cash do we care look
I live in Manchester and I've been
covering the Manchester United Sales
first seven months now
um the majority of Manchester United
fans want the qataris to win this yeah
battle because they just see an
opportunity to to be out back back up
with the big boys in terms of spending
in terms of being able to take on what
they see as a Potential Threat well a
clear threat from Newcastle down the
line but more more locally from
Manchester City right so so they that so
they want that um I think it is you know
the horse is bolted I think they're here
to stay I sat with I agree
representatives of the Saudis when I was
in Qatar I sat with the qataris they
want the World Cup in in Saudi Arabia
yeah they want the Olympics yes you know
David let me bring you in a lot of
business around the world right we met
we had a nice cup of tea in Qatar and it
was an amazingly well-run World Cup the
best everyone had a great time I thought
I thought the best Graham Sooners told
me it was the best you've been to
um but there is there are obviously
political issues here you can't divorce
politics and Sport obviously some of
these countries like Saudi Arabia have
very bad records on human rights and you
can't ignore that in all this and
obviously they're trying to improve
their image where's the line for you
well there is a balance firstly how do
you stop overseas investment and it's
been going on for years you take
Rolls-Royce cars who owns the
Rolls-Royce wanna be
what the best times in English car
manufacturer who owns it BMW who who
owns
um Harrods state of Qatar who owns
Coleman's mustard if you like less art
subject who I you know who Unilever of
Holland so you're always going to get
overseas a verse we're going to your
newspaper mat I mean we're not making a
huge fuss about the fact that the
Chinese have huge stakes in our critical
National infrastructure I mean that's
arguably much more worrying than
anything that we're seeing here and the
point you made about the Saudis wanting
to get their own people involved I've
looked at their Vision 2030 an
incredible plan for how they're going to
transform in every little way and it's
it's from the big to the small for
example they want to raise life
expectancy from 74 to 80 there they've
got very specific plans about how much
sport they want everybody to be doing
every week I think it would it would
behold the UK to slightly reduce our
moral High Ground on this because
honestly there is no called Financial
FAIR Plan existence yeah so there there
is a leveling and it's meant to and it
will work eventually if you put ready
but if these charges against City are
true or even half of them are true they
have trampled all over that's that's
another story and as I say that's yet to
be proven
you what I mentioned two quick things
before we let you uh oh that's very kind
yes
um if we can talk football for two
minutes
so I'm on two two campaigns to do with
football one is time keeping because you
know how long it takes to score a goal
mat four minute all right four man move
guy scores how long does it take
35 seconds 10 seconds okay so when they
when the fourth official puts up three
or four minutes is the accurate the last
10 seconds no he's not I want that the
time loss I'm not talking about four
minutes and get rid of VAR which is I'm
a great believer in Vaughn I think it
helps the referees we're all talking
about until the joy out of football
we'll have to disagree on that one
because come back another time we'll
debate so anyway I'm on time keeping I
want to eventually see real time I want
the fans to realize they're gonna get 60
Minutes of actually pure football are
they fans would agree what's the other
one that's another one the other one is
penalty shootouts believe it or not why
is it that the penalties are taken at
one end which has to be a disadvantage
to the opposing team I want to see
penalties taken at either end so let's
take the Cup Final you have Man City
taking their penalties
so at least the no you take it at your
own at where you've got 20 or 30 000
fans you're depriving me of the joy of
watching somebody from Tottenham taking
your penalty against also and fifty
thousand dollars booing at him well yeah
and I don't want you doing that how does
a penalty how does he feel how the fans
at the wrong end of the pitch feel when
they've got to watch it down the other
end well look as always you're an
innovator you always have been that's
why my clubs in such a great condition
thanks to you and all you did so thank
you again for that thank you very much
great story tonight it's going to be
very interesting how this all plays out
when we get more details of more of
these charges Isabel thank you as always
for your perspective if you'd like to
watch and thank you to Damon as well for
joining us Damon Collins over there I
appreciate it if you want to watch
Britain's biggest football Scandal it's
available on YouTube now and it has more
of this story about Manchester City Ron
says the next day you've got to living
like a king you figure show the Royal
spending is rocketed I think they're
worth every penny the royal family and
I've invited two Royal naysayers who
think they're worth nothing to come and
try and prove me wrong to get a little
Lively
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
debate I have strong opinions but like
all the world's eminent thinkers I'm
open to changing my mind so tonight I'm
trying something a little new
don't be wrong it's the title of his new
segment first up is the royal family
worth the money the annual Crown report
into Royal finances was released today
King Charles and co-appeared were maxed
out the Royal credit card last year they
spent 107 million pounds while The
Sovereign Grant was only 86.3 million
pounds that means we're in the hole for
around 20.7 million pounds extra big
numbers indisputably but in my view the
royal family still represents stunningly
good value I say they're worth every
penny here to debate the complete
opposite Alex O'Connor the YouTuber and
Royal skeptic and Graham Smith chief
executive of the UK's leading Republican
movement Republic who's just handed me
his new book abolish the monarchy why we
should and how we will so clear we're on
different uh we're on different paths
here but the rules are simple you guys
have until you hear this sound
to prove me wrong I say the Royals are
worth every penny that this country
gives them which by the way is literally
really one penny per person in this
country a year
per day birthday so it's a penny a day
per person in the country well it's not
and the point the first thing to say
about this this debate is that the
monarchy is not a financial transaction
so whether it's got makes a profit or
not is neither here nor there the
measure of whether it's a good
institution and worth keeping is whether
it's good constitutionally because
that's what it's there for why are you
so against it and out of interest
because firstly the whole life is
devoted to ending the monarchy
personally it's wrong in principle it's
not Democratic it stands on completely
different set of feudal values instead
of the values of accountability equality
and Democratic rights and so on secondly
as an institution it is not fit for
purpose it falls well short of the
principles of public life
um I don't think it's going too far to
say it's corrupt and constitutionally in
terms of our politics and and the way
power is exercised it funnels a lot of
power what have been the four most
watched events globally involving this
country in the last three years yeah but
that doesn't really
yeah going to say the weddings and the
Jews I'll answer my question you're
going to say the weddings in the
jubilees I'm not sure that's even the
case because I think UEFA had um well
forget it forget football okay we can't
just say forget football it's National
events National events success
universally show this country
nine percent of this country were
enthusiastic about the coronation 15 by
another poll so you know in terms of
royalists most people you know people
that you can genuinely call royalists is
less than 15 all right but see here's
the point I think which I think you both
you guys are missing but I mean trying
to convince me Alex I just think when
the world looked at the Platinum Jubilee
for example when the world looked in a
very different tone at the Queen's
funeral the king's coronation you look
at these events and it shows Britain in
my view at its greatest the pomp the
pageantry the ceremony the military
Precision everything worked like
clockwork everyone around the world who
was watching this who was watching like
it was a caveat many people are not
interested that but the millions tens of
millions around the world that watched
it thought better of our country how
many things has happened in our country
in the last three years involving our
leaders for example which have brought
shame and ignominy to the country here
you have a chance to show us at our best
what price do you put on there's nothing
about the royal family that's brought us
shame in your opinion that you've been
sort of things relentlessly that's the
idea that the human beings
and you say you know it doesn't help us
to escape the various political scandals
of prime ministers and presidents well
it does it I I thought you were the one
who's constantly banging on about Harry
and Megan and how there are disgrace to
our country or whatever it is I don't
think well I think I think rather like
YouTube there are attempts to damage the
monarchy and bring it down are actually
disgraceful because I happen to support
the monarchy of an argument a few big
events is not an argument for a
Constitution which is second rate it's
not an argument for an institution that
abuses public money that abuses public
office to lobby for their interests and
so on I mean you know 12 was it 13 years
ago 14 years ago now the MP's expenses
Scandal
um I'm sure you were one of the the many
commentators who are outraged by MP
spending public money on their own homes
their second homes yeah and that was
sort of hundreds of pounds thousands of
pounds sometimes tens of thousands of
pounds the Royals spend Millions tens of
millions you know my view about my view
of that our money if you're going to
happen if you're going to have a
monarchy and a royal family and they're
performing over a thousand duties a year
which is not a lot well they're actually
getting lots of charities
help for people right they couldn't do
his private citizens well they could
they wouldn't have the same impact okay
but here's my here's my point here's my
point if you're going to have them you
should give them all the trappings WoW
otherwise they're not a royal family I'm
not a monarchy where's the logic is that
if you want people to buy into the magic
of a monarchy and royal family you've
got to give them the tools but it should
be magic it's not magic it's corruption
what would you have them in a little
just Tesla I mean maybe a maybe a suit
that'd be fine we could start by getting
rid of these ridiculous garments we
spent most of the time that we've known
just like dressed like me and so to see
him for the first time you're on the
king dressed like No Effects well he'd
probably put on a tie it looked more
like you I suppose yes to see and
suddenly put on these robes would be
like watching Rishi sunak or someone
suddenly a lot of our history questions
it gives us something it's so few other
countries
many around the world love it if you go
to the Caribbean if you go to America
you go to Canada you go to India you go
anywhere in the world Australia and they
bring you just so much money from
tourism well that's not true but it is
true
now the thing is there is no evidence
and I've sat down with the CEO and chair
visit Britain uh about a decade ago and
I said there's no evidence that if we
got rid of the monarchy tourism would go
down and they said yes you absolutely
you don't think the royal family brings
in any money no evidence that that
tourism money wouldn't come in anyway I
mean if you don't like the history just
look at the money that came in in the
weeks leading up to these big events
that we've had about before you look at
these huge amounts of money if you look
at the visiting number American tourists
the visitors
always go down when these things happen
if you look at the visitor numbers they
go down when these people stay away from
these kind of things and and I may say
Cheshire zoo is a bigger tourist
attraction in the UK than Buckingham
Palace or Windsor Castle I wouldn't be
in favor of a state-funded ceremony
I certainly what's the birth of a
penguin at Chester Zoo I certainly would
not be in favor don't do they oh it's
owners or its directors or indeed the
the the sort of sometimes Sinister and
yet still to be pitied animals that are
kept within its cages
the justification for political office
where the thing that the tourists are
spending money on is not the way to
decide what about uh Williams campaign
at the moment to end homelessness yeah
fantastic funded by what funded by us
and what's his name
the most ludicrous thing you've said on
this show and that says a lot
the bar is low I agree to say that this
is something that requires royalty say
this is something that requires he has
some kind of political office that he's
going to inherit the head of uh head of
statehood that he's going to become the
head of state of this country they've
got anything to do with his ability to
get three million pounds of Charity
guys you argue a case with great Passion
but in the end it's just a negative
anti-harmony no it's not that's what you
are not at all a pair of you wake up
every day and you think how do I end
this thing I hate why don't you just
ignore it it's a bit like you see what
it is we're having a vegan debate in a
minute it's a bit like vegans you run
into steakhouses screaming abuse
it's actually a bit like getting up in
the morning saying I want to end
homelessness because I hate it I want to
end monetary because it is a bad thing
it's bad it's bad for our government
it's bad for our governance
ceremony when it comes to two out of the
three times
you've invited me to those are two of
the three times that I've ever spoken
about the subject in public yeah it's
because you've invited me to so I don't
think it's me who's banging on about
this it's not me who's waking up every
day just desperate to see it again
every time we call you your answering
machine says if that's peers I'll do it
so don't blame me uh the claxter's gone
the big question have you I think we
know where this is going behind the
first one but have you proven me wrong
no yeah we convinced you is another
question you have it the thing is read
my book and then come back to me I will
read your book but I've done a pretty
good idea what's in it because it's got
Owen Jones quote on the front singing
crucial riveting poleming and what Owen
Jones knows about crucial riveting
polemics can be written on a postage
stamp which I
yeah say well there's a lot more Royal
fans than you think uh gentlemen good to
see you thank you your campaign will
fail but it will fail with passion and I
admire that I bet you're a tenor okay
is that 10 pounds with King Charles's
picture on it yes it is uncensored next
somebody's Chef John Mountain
sensationally bans vegans from his
restaurant he says it's to protect his
mental health he joins me next live
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
welcome back to Facebook veganism the
art of issuing all pleasure in life is
one of the 21st Century's most bizarre
Trends from where I look at it but there
are green plant-based shoots of recovery
the new fashion is for high-profile
vegans including Explorer Bear Grylls to
preventing the de-transitioning back to
healthy meaty diets and so many chefs
like John Mountain who runs Fire
restaurant in Perth Australia is also
dealing the fight back he's made Global
headlines this week after announcing
sadly all vegans are banned from fire
for mental health reasons we thank you
for your understanding many didn't
understand he's been flooded with fake
bookings and hostile reviews but I'm
joined now by the vegan ban himself John
mountain and here in the studio animal
rights activist Joey carb strong well
welcome to both of you okay John
Mountain why did you ban vegans from
your restaurant
uh morning peers I banned them from my
restaurant because look I've been a chef
for nearly 30 years but on this
particular incident it was just too much
you know they grouped together which you
know I'm very proud of the vegans for
all sticking together but they did they
grouped and banded together and then
started hammering my business with one
star reviews I saw my rating dropped
from a sensible 4.2 down to 2.8 they
they nearly broke me God bless the
vegans though what was the incident that
provoked all this
the problem that happened was a girl had
emailed me three weeks before uh
requesting a vegan selection and I said
well look rather than saying that what
is it that you like tell me what you
like and she said well
you know I like gnocchi and risotto I
thought okay no problem we change our
menu every day peers so it's not an
issue the problem was on the day that
she did turn up I I couldn't do it I I
let her down and it was a justifiable
complaint
and she went nuts
cool but yeah slightly nuts my thing
about vegans is they tend to be I don't
know they seem to be permanently hangry
like the lack of meat in their diet
makes them very intolerant of people and
they get very agitated and if you don't
sign up to all things vegan in the way
that they want you to all hell breaks
loose
I think that seems to be the issue
um appears to be honest I think they're
just missing a really good burger or a
glass of milk you know or both uh you
know they need to sleep more be a bit
more healthy although you know the vegan
diet allegedly is healthy just not for
everybody else you know I think each to
their own is one okay okay let's come to
Joey it's a joey Bay Grill so I know
well so he's embarrassed to use to
promote veganism uh he now eats a diet
of red meat blood bone marrow as well as
salted butter eggs fruit and honey says
he's never felt better talking about his
transition to a vegan diet so I was
vegan quite a few years ago I thought I
wrote a vegan cookbook I now feel a bit
embarrassed about that because I
promoted I thought that was good for the
environment I thought it was good for my
health and through time and experience
and knowledge and study I realized I was
wrong on both
he's embarrassed to that he promoted a
plant-based diet when he drinks urine
and buy a lot of camel's stomach is
quite healthy it's healthy would you
drink urine would you rather drink urine
absolutely
he's embarrassed that he uh now that he
uh promoted a vegan diet and he's not
embarrassed of his behavior on TV and he
thinks that eating the bodies why are
vegans so angry
well um he he made a statement saying uh
the vegans are angry and angry but he
carried on and banned all vegans from
his restaurant because of one simple
complaint he's not allowed to yeah he's
allowed to ban a whole group of people
he's a chef he's just sick of tailoring
to vegan people who want to have all
this stuff and get angry about me listen
listen wait a second he he got a two uh
he got a two-star review when he was on
a Great British menu right he ripped off
his mic smashed up the studio and said
that he wanted to kill the guy for
giving him a two-star review of a fish
dish that he made he didn't ban all Fish
Eaters
Joey listen we're gonna get it personal
you were a gang member so don't take the
high moral grandmother I'm smashing
something I'm completely honest about it
there's been documentaries I don't take
the high moral ground about losing your
temper literally in the game I was 10
years ago 10 years sober now you're
going to use it to say if you're going
to get personal with it but anyways I
don't walk around with uh dead baby pigs
facing them like that like does that
look like somebody else like you know
they're horrible have you seen footage
from inside a gas station I recently
exposed one in the UK yeah
in Perth there's a gas chamber called
Lily Valley pork right and this guy
observes pork at his restaurant and why
would you be more upset that of a little
complaint as a chef then pigs being
murdered okay let me ask you the
question that I asked a vegan activist
the other day which is that given that
uh 80 or 90 of the world's almonds come
from California where there are made in
the involving the demolition of billions
of bees who get murdered how do you feel
about them don't get murdered and that's
completely false and I don't know how
many billions how many billions die in
in the pollination I've got the 2022
data right on here they die mostly from
parasites and pests 66 die of uh
barrower mites or other pests and
parasites in the main disease in the
making excuse me almonds and avocados oh
they do they do the dangerous it's this
year do you know where I read serious
dates from U.S department of Agriculture
do you know where I read this I read it
in the guardian the vegan Bible even the
guardian excuse me admitted that you
vegans avocados 6.7 this is not don't
care about the little guys billions of
beans and you don't care where do those
bees come from uh where are those in
America they come from all over the
country the commercial honey industry
that's true and a lot of them wake up
what a big vegan's boycott gone the
commercial honey why don't you boil your
arms and avocados because I don't see a
reason to most of the bees are dying
from mice
okay all right listen so you don't care
about them 36 die from pesticides so
it's not really a rights violation not
murdering here's my point
a big pig makes you cry a little bit you
don't you don't care no listen you don't
care about it there's no reason to be
upset sometimes pollination sometimes
they die from Millions
over each other sometimes 50 billion
bees die in six months to give you vegan
literally
that's not true agricultural stuff
read the guardian I read it in an
article let me an anecdote so it must be
true how long have you been a vegan uh
ten years right do you actually because
you seem quite agitated to me like you
want a bit about nonsense about bees
being murdered when they die from they
are murdered they're murdered
Behavior but you think in a way you
represent what I feel about Vegas you're
all quite hungry are you Against Animal
Cruelty peers yes then why do you
support animal cruelty when you support
them you don't I've defended the bees
for years
they're not murdered billions of bees
are murdered
honey where they're hired from John let
me let me bring in John here uh John
look here's my point about the vegans
there's a lot of hypocrisy as there is
with all these debates right which is
that if you want to eat almonds and
avocados as a vegan you feel virtuous
you think you're saving the planet as
well actually neither of those things
are true billions of bees get killed to
make almonds and avocados people can go
read the the proper reports about this
yeah and also they fly the men around
the world or they Chuck them around the
world and they call that it's terrible
for the for the Planet truck animal
products around the world do you believe
John there's a kind of basic hypocrisy
here with the vegans
look I I think peers what I've noticed
is that there's there's a strange
correlation that they have between
um eating meat and death and murder
which they'd like to keep promoting that
murder aside I think if they look at the
definition of murder you know this is
human versus human and that is it you
know look I'm 100 Against Animal Cruelty
and for him to bring up the Great
British menu well it just shows his
mentality you know good lad
congratulations well done it's not what
we're about I think each should be to
their own and you should just enjoy your
life you know if they're gonna argue
peers
killing animals look at this Joey it's
supposed to take the murdered people
yeah
it wasn't just you can't handle a simple
complaint from and this woman she's a
very nice respect to this young woman
it's very nice very kind very polite and
you can't handle a symptom Joey let me
ask you a question celebrity
everyone watching this either on the
show tonight or on YouTube later go and
Google bees US Departments
right here avocados and you'll see the
truth and the truth even the guardian
where they all are compelled to eat
lentils every day when they wear their
sandals to work this is a gas chamber
piece this is how pigs are killed and
explored in the UK this is my
investigation thank you a question why
don't you play me why don't you play me
the sound of billions of bees being
murdered
right look at them face them what do you
think bees do what do you think bees do
when you murder them they get killed by
mice this is gas chamber look at us they
get slaughtered their account cowardly I
know that animals get slaughtered so
that I can eat animals stuck this camera
in this gas chamber in the UK at
Pilgrim's Pride and they scream for
their lives and every single animal
welfare here's my problem here's my
problem and you want bacon and you
promote it I love bacon you promote it I
love bacon you say you're against that I
love sausages I love it all I love
eating meat you love animal cruelty yeah
I'm prepared to admit I love eating meat
you're not prepared to denounce avocado
and almonds because you're making upset
they don't care because they actually
lead to pollination
these are the final word to John John is
there anything that will beside your
mind to let vegans in
there's obviously he'd be a fantastic
guest in your restaurant
discrimination isn't it thank you peers
absolutely childish childish behavior
discriminating against the whole group
of people because of one little silly
complaint go ahead
last time I laughed when I heard you say
that all bees are slaughtered because of
avocados it's an absolute objective it's
an absolute facts don't care about your
feelings yeah
final word is how many vegans does it
take to change a light bulb
go on
none
we'll wait for the punchline what's the
punchline
go have a crime to stay in the dark
go have a question the other one I like
is how do you know when someone's vegan
don't worry gas chamber footage don't
worry you can they'll soon tell you and
play uh pictures and stuff of people
murdered well they won't play you it's
beesbeam uh Joey great to see you John
thank you for joining me for birth on
Saturdays the Rwanda migrant plan is
ruled unlawful again and Madonna's back
at home after six days stay in intensive
care the beers back returns to Feast on
today's events
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
coming up next the Prime Minister slams
The Court ruling that the Rwanda migrant
plan is unlawful the royal family
reveals how it spends its money and
there's outrage over NHS doctors doing
private work while on strike that's all
at nine o'clock on the talk
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Facebook joining me now
talk to your contributors Paul Ron
Adrian and Richard Thai Stewie avocados
and almonds delicious absolutely
delicious guilty about the bees they do
I do actually enough to stop eating them
yeah absolutely you're giving up
avocados right now I will give up
avocados and almonds because of what you
said because without insects we are
going to die without bees we all die
absolutely agree bees are it's the
vegans keep killing bees the planet's
over
that's why vegans are so dangerous let's
tell us some other stories um the Rwanda
plan today Richard ruled unlawful uh
Rishi Cena says the government will
appeal this ruling descend Asylum
Seekers to Rwanda but the court of
appeal judges ruled romander had not
provided enough safeguards to prove it
is a safe Third Country to send people
uh prime minister says he fundamentally
disagrees but it's another massive blow
and what it does do he shoves it the can
down the road again no one was getting
on planes to Rwanda anytime soon Richie
sooner is running out of time to deliver
on this isn't he yeah I mean he has
pledged to stop the boats and he's not
going to stop the boats yesterday the
House of Lords uh they put another Block
in the way they don't want to stop the
boats today you've got a court of appeal
here's the thing though what they didn't
do was look last week last Tuesday World
Refugee day and in Rwanda the unhcr's
own representative said that 132 000
refugees in Rwanda were thriving with
education and employment opportunity
okay let's let's forget about what's
happening in Rwanda for a second let's
forget what's happening Even in our
courts and let's deal with the figures
and what practically this the government
is telling us the government is telling
us that it's going to cost 169 000
pounds to send one Asylum Seeker to
Rwanda Rwanda tells us hang on a minute
we can only take between 200 to a
thousand actually who are going to apply
and we know that last year 46
000 so we don't need to talk about the
course of appeal decision we don't we
need to talk about what's happening
it's never going to work we are yes we
have fooled into believable
they don't want to stop the base Richard
I agree the British establishment does
not want to stop the votes the best we
have Network migration making so much
profits you've got to stock the boats
the kind and compassionate thing to do
is to pick up and safely take back which
we're entitled to do under existing
International
systems by which they can we've already
got the 1.2 million
this is 606 000. we came here through
safe and legal routes using a lawful
Visa system not not Asylum Seekers that
is different and that is different and
they play and that is what they are
playing on they're playing so what
happens the most vulnerable so what
happens if someone is rejected because
they're an Albanian or they're an
economic migrant and they're rejected
under your safer neighborhood
they will continue to come illegal your
safe and legal point is completely it's
a water boundary we need a deterrent
it's got to be strong it's got all right
given how well you're both getting on
what's been your what's been your
favorite chat up line you've ever heard
oh it's too long ago peers I can't
remember
peers I wish I could control the
alphabet because I would turn you and I
together
all are you naughty girls
um apparently Brits were pulled on this
and their favorite was is your name
Wi-Fi because I'm feeling a connection
of a God's sake has anyone ever thought
of this other ones included is your name
Google because you're what I've been
searching for are you a parking ticket
you've got fine written all over you
should we get a coffee I like you a
latte oh my God's sake right is it
anyone there's so many people are single
on this guy some of these words didn't
exist when I was dating this
unbelievable quick other serious uh
story the story of the RAF
discriminating against white men
fascinating the RAF has been found to
have unlawfully discriminated against
white men in a recruitment Drive aimed
at boosting diversity 72-page report
ordered by the former RAF head air Chief
Marshall and it's come back and said
yeah this was completely wrong more than
30 member identified as having missed
out on a potential 5 000 pound golden
handshake to start cyber roles in the
RAF what do you make this well this is
absurd I mean this is all of this drive
for diversity inclusion and equality
which is a good thing in itself but when
it goes completely the other way to the
other end of the spectrum actually all
of a sudden there's other forms of
discrimination what about the best
person for the job isn't that a basic
sort of common sense I mean and I would
agree with you but you know absolutely
but you know that that doesn't work
that's that that doesn't deal that
doesn't lit that's not our reality
Richard it's not my reality it's not
many people of colors reality that the
best person always gets the job and that
is the problem however of course you
have to accept that it was unlawful you
cannot have positive discrimination and
it's right that this decision came out I
absolutely support that because what
actually the RAF should have done is
consulted and and perhaps they didn't
consult in the way they should have done
in terms of inclusive because you do
want to have obviously diversity
inclusion of course you do and you want
everyone to get a fair crack of the whip
regardless of skin color gender
sexuality whatever it may be but when
you see stories like this of active
discrimination against white men to try
and achieve this it is fundamentally
wrong because of course it's where's the
common sense in this where's the sense
that yes you want to do the right thing
um and and give everybody an equal
opportunity and then choose the best
person I don't think that's that
difficult and look we're we're so much
better a place than we were 20 years
back this pain that you're feeling and
the next time is that your latest chat
outline
that is
pain you're feeling Richard's eyes we've
got to leave you there great to see
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
I'm off for a drink with Paula
[Music]
foreign